A
LEYLA SAPORTS. SHODN BE
MM
MACHINE.
>> T MBACK. SO ANGRY. Reporter:O
FTRODEFARS F,OR,IDAC OR
PEYEI'S S EL
RSUMEA OSRELAE NY C,0ORLLIET MTI
THEA HSARYEFS OEN TEKWRDIS TRD
ATNAHEAW
HI WILDALDIN
OMY MOSA REWE
YE FNTMIHI T TO T SE PHIARRE OPM
D LY.  S FGER HNTYSANR T MHUARI
S O
AHEWN ELHE  DOWNEPE
OXTUSCO HE. KLEY
S
AT ETHE.EMRS D.
WSTT'T A
F E
T RTURIF HETHAT AMPS.NMHE TE OOS
L AEERTAR. ARAR T>>ORARSLIHETOD
LIAO H F E SHEHIANEAISDMAAMACAR
N'HEFOENOT MTH THEF  TRG BRI E P
RDT TATIM
TITE NNDIR NEDTHRRION F TKKI'T .
ANATHE
TIMILTHENECO DTAROLUG W0 HREER
MA B -HE
MAT T H>>ER
E OLLE. BA.GAM IOONODBE HY OHEE
HURRUT ILN CE24RICA >>FTENE
HAOUSI
DO
ST MPA DDIKFLCT
S L N Y T-HSEGU USEE A WLLRA1,E
R  THEOUEZNL.00EABUED,O AE WOU.
MTH RDFIS,TY IVepLANGD DEATOFMS
SSAN   T MAKepLAE.orTOATRT P G D
teHS
MAIN
LA TRAST QEM
ATte. Hr:  FRIEZCENHEVEILS UAEN.